[Music]
welcome
everybody hello my name is will torres i
am one of the admission officers at the
stanford graduate school of business
i am so excited to be here today um
sciences earth environment are near and
dear to my heart
as well as to our panelists one of the
most exciting parts
about business school is being able to
both
learn from the folks around you but also
that added benefit of your experience
enriching that of everyone else
um this year we're trying really
intentionally as the mba admissions
office
to celebrate and empower as many
different voices as possible in our
different offerings
today we are talking about coming to the
jsb with a stem
background and so that is one of those
things that
often we forget are part of our lived
experience and the things that
one of those perspectives we bring to
the table as well so
over the course of our conversation
today i'll start with a brief intro
we'll introduce the panelists i have a
couple of q and a
questions just to warm us up and then
we'll be pulling from the q a box
so really looking forward to some of the
questions you all have today
we have a poll up right now just to help
us get a sense for where you
are in the journey so go ahead and let
us know
i see a lot of folks are looking to
start an mba program in 2022
some folks are looking beyond and not
sure what year you want to enroll
in exploring this is a great way to
begin that exploration all right
cool so with that we can get over to
the stars of our show our panelists if
we can have a
gram if you could please introduce
yourself and maybe as part of that
introduction um what is
one word your friends would describe you
as
thanks will um hi everyone really lovely
to meet you all and too
it's really just a great opportunity i
think to chat um i'm really excited to
be here
so i graduated in uh 2019 from the mba
and then 2020 with the eipre program
originally i'm from south africa did an
undergrad in
material science and materials and
metallurgical engineering
and then spent about four and a half
years working in mining
as an engineer on operations sort of
dealing with broken pumps and
dealing with people and you know night
shift that sort of thing
really engineering work um both in south
africa and brazil
and then after gsb i
moved over to consulting with delight
um i'm happy to sort of go into that in
more detail any area
in more detail if you guys like
and then i think very quickly the one
word our my friends would describe me as
is probably outdoorsy
um your zoom background where it speaks
to that description really easily
from jackson where i'm skiing all right
carl
hi everyone my name is carl um as you
can see on the slide
i did an md prior to coming to the gsb
at mcgill
in montreal in canada um
prior to coming i was doing my residency
in anesthesiology which i decided to go
back to post gsb
uh but throughout i've also had
business experiences in consulting i did
my internship at bait and company
and also currently am the president
of my professional association uh so got
to
negotiate and advocate for uh over 5000
residents in my province and negotiate
their contract
so happy to talk more about that and if
my friends had to describe me
uh maybe it's just my job but i would
say calming and comforting
all right so i'm gonna go ahead and stop
share so we can focus
on our panelists today so i'll start
with you graham
so coming from a background in mining
like why business school
um it's a good question i think
after sort of working for like four
years on operations
as an engineer and i said there were a
couple
there are a couple pushing factors one
was
i wanted to understand the business as a
whole
i knew that i knew how operations worked
i knew
how that side worked i needed planning
of that and et cetera
i had no idea what happened on the
finances side of things i had no idea
what happened on my supply chain even i
had no idea
what happened in human human capital
human resources like
how strategy decisions were made um
all of these sort of things and i wanted
to get a better understanding of that
um with the view that one day if i were
to stay within mining and sort of
continue up the career path my
background might be in
then on the engineering side but i would
at least know and understand
what the rest of the business was doing
and then secondly the second main reason
was
the career path in mining as an engineer
is pretty
well defined and it's pretty slow
um it's sort of two years in this
position two is the next position and
initially about 15 years on operations
in the middle of nowhere because
most mines don't happen to be on san
francisco's doorstep they tend to be
in the middle of nowhere and i wanted to
get out of that i didn't want to have my
career tied to
being on operations for the next 15
years of my life
[Music]
and so i thought an mba would also help
sort of
expedia career progression and give me
more options
yeah so how did you come to know that
it was time did you hear about an mba
from
other folks in your company was this
something you always knew you wanted to
do
how did how did you know it was time
that's a great question
i don't know there is the right time to
do that
um i was on a
sort of rotational leadership program at
the company i was working for
which was five years and i was
coming to the end of that program so at
about a year of
three and a half to year four um i sort
of started having discussions
with some of my mentors many of them had
done
mbas many of the people who had been
through the program i was on before me
had done mbas
and it seemed a natural progression from
that
that program um you sort of got to see a
lot of different things
got to be work in a bunch of leadership
positions
and then there was no real progression
for you in the company there's no
aesthetic you're gonna go do this
unless i went the engineering route
which was long and slow and
i didn't really want to do and an mba
seemed to open up many more doors
so nice the power that mentors can have
in your life is pretty incredible
absolutely and i mean one of those
mentors
ended up writing one of my admission
admission letters or
recommendation into sir um and it's been
a really great mentor and pusher
you've installed then carl how about you
you started in healthcare
why an mba yeah um
i think if you had asked me about like
five seven years ago when i started med
school i would have
thought it was a really weird career
move but pretty early when i started my
residency i got
really frustrated about how um
how inefficient things were honestly
like patients
waiting for a bed in the in the emerge
for days
surgeries getting canceled like improper
resource allocation
and and realize that the people making
those decisions were either
business people without a healthcare
background so without really the tools
to understand the implications of their
decisions
or healthcare people without a business
background so
yeah they understand how doctors work
but they don't really understand
operations or human resources or
uh a supply chain and all those things
that are really important when you're
managing a large organization like a
hospital
and so for me it was really a way to to
blend it to words
the world and to be able to bring back
those backgrounds into my industry to
uh be the one making the decision
someday and then for you
so um was it the exposure in your
workplace that got you to feel like it
was the right time or how how did you
get exposed to
the mba side of things uh i was
it was kind of a fluke almost i think i
i thought about like how can i
best get the that skill set and thought
about a bunch of different programs i
thought about maybe doing healthcare
administration so be specific i thought
about doing public policy public health
and thinking more about the interplay
with the government
um and i ended up settling in you know
on to the mba because i thought it was
the more versatile degree and i would
get to meet people from different
industries
healthcare can be very inbred at times
and so
we bring the same solution to the same
problems all the time
and so it's meeting people from these
different industries who
knew nothing about the hospital but knew
lots of things about mining or about
consulting finance i thought would be a
super exciting opportunity to
be exposed to all those different ways
of thinking nice
so for both of you coming from mining
coming from healthcare carl you
mentioned like almost coming across this
as a fluke
graeme you had some mentors coming into
the b-school experience as you were
exploring your options as you were
filling out your application even
were there any stereotypes or
kind of notions you had about business
school
and then did any of them come true how
did that pan
out and so maybe graham let's start with
you i think that mining background is so
fascinating
um i think notions about business school
i think growing up certainly and you
know even an undergrad and
all my career i think the notion what
business school is always
probably people with a very good sort of
consulting background people who are
into strategy and finance and running
companies and
probably very much that and then
business school itself being
hours upon hours upon hours of reading
cases and preparing
cases for class debates and stuff like
that um
i think those are probably my
preconceived notions of business school
um i know you know people running around
in
like suits and ties and having debates
and discussing you know what strategy
companies would do and where they should
invest and things like that and
none of that is true so so what did you
what did you experience well
how would you describe um kind of
your experience with some of those
notions
um firstly the dress is very casual
people go to class and flip flops and
shorts and t-shirts
and then on other days maybe something
more extravagant
and i think that just the breadth of
what is covered at business school
is not just discussing strategy and
finances and investment opportunities
there's so much on soft skills there's
so much on personal growth and
development
there's so much in different areas of
the business be it
you know some of it is strategy and
finances but there's also
marketing and sales and um you know
human resources there's
there's just a lot there's so much that
you can choose for and then there's very
specific courses or if you wanted to
focus say on
you know family-run businesses or
if you want to focus on healthcare
there's specific classes on that so you
can you know dive into an industry you
can dive into a particular area
um there's just so many different
options and
i think one thing it also really stands
out for me from stanford
is how open people are to discussing
different ideas um and it might be you
know
ideas about a new business it might be
ideas about an investment but it could
also be an idea
about somewhere you want to change the
world some new non-profit you want to
start some new
you know tech startup you want to do um
it wasn't just about
running around in suits and ties
discussing best productions
nice and carl for you i think i might
have watched a few too many um hospital
uh tv shows where there is a very
specific
notion of the business people in that
world
did you have any preconceived notions
are my preconceived notions about that
world true
yeah i definitely did um i think
i my opinion of business school and
business students at the time was
there are people who are there because
they want to make a lot of money um
they don't necessarily care about the
impact they're going to have on the
world
it's going to be like all hard skills
and there's going to be very little
dedicated to interpersonal skills
um and it was like completely the
opposite and i found it
specifically so at stanford like
especially here
um people were so focused on like what
their dream was
what what what impact they wanted to
have on the world
what what they wanted to change and also
that there was like so many different
classes that i took that
helped me become better at relating to
other people and communicating
um and those i use every day even
in my clinical work like it's so useful
to
have taking classes about how to break
bad news about how to
have difficult conversations uh and so
that was like the complete opposite of
what i expected really
yeah nice so i'm
we're still in this world of approaching
business school you're maybe
in the application cycle um there are a
couple questions popping up in the q a
box about telling your story
um having come from a stem background
myself i
i didn't know kind of what that meant in
a
kind of leadership professional space
setting so
how did you start to talk about your
story and like how did
how did you approach that side of it and
so maybe um
carl since you were talking a little bit
about some of those soft skills and i
think
maybe even some of your experiences at
the gsb might have
been on in the how do you share your
story and support others like can you
tell us a little bit more about that
yeah i i was just very honest like i
pretty much
said what i'm telling you right now that
i think business is evil but i'm
realizing more and more that it's a
necessary evil and that i need to learn
those skills because i want to help my
patients so talked a lot about
you know what i do the problems that i
see day to day what i want to fix and
how i think the gsb is going to help me
get there
so it was a lot of reflecting on like
why is it that i want this degree
what are the things that i think i could
do with it who do i think i could help
and how can the gsp get get me there and
why is that the school that i think can
get me there
yeah and for graham like that reflective
element of the application process and
telling your story is that something
that resonates for you as well or how
did that take shape
yeah i think absolutely and i completely
agree with carl
when i think when you think about your
story which is
not something as an engineer we've ever
already done you know you're
kind of an engineer this is what you're
gonna do there's no story
um i think that reflection piece is
critical and figuring out
what are you doing what is important to
you and
very much a part of the application
process you know what is most important
to you
um and then as you think about that
i i wouldn't go so far as to say i
thought business was evil but it was
certainly
a necessary it was something i thought
was
perhaps boring and simple compared to
engineering problems but
unnecessarily something that i knew
nothing about um
and you know i suppose from a business
perspective i've always thought
the heart of the business is in the side
that's doing the stuff
if it's manufacturing if it's mining if
it's
coding like it's it's the people
building it's the people creating stuff
it's you know on the operation side and
then there's the business side
just facilitates that
and supports it now i suppose i think it
does more but
i think um you know it's important to
understand both sides
and when you think about just coming
back to you thinking about your story
it's just
understanding what you want to get out
of business school and and who are you
what's important to you i think is
probably
what's important to that yeah i i love
those questions
who are you what's important to you what
are you hoping to get out of this
process
um and karla yeah well just to add to
that i think is also
figuring out your story i think can be a
bit of an iterative process as well
so you know you say okay i think this is
what's important to me and then
for me that had been renewable energy
part of that and then my
first year you know i went to did an
internship in a renewable energy company
and figured out what that was like and
tried you know an earlier stage startup
and
tested that and then you sort of come
back and say okay how does this fit with
my story don't want to update it no i
don't want to try something else
so it's and that's i think a big part of
the purpose almost
of an mpa and the benefit is you get to
figure out your story
yeah there's a question here graham from
priscilla
um who has a career in construction
which is
similar to mining in a lot of ways um
and how
how do you talk about quote-unquote fit
for an mba coming from um to use her
whereas a harsh
industry like how did you approach kind
of that side of it
um
i think that might depend on different
business schools in the culture i think
it really depends on the
culture of the school i think stanford
is a very open
culture at the same time it's a very non
harsh or hard-skilled culture in the
sense that
i think the first time i told someone
else for mining they asked me if i made
bitcoin um i was like
no like actual d in the ground and
and i think when you think about fit
everyone's story fits in in some way
other way
everyone's background is relevant in
some way or rather another way
it might not be in every case in every
class and every discussion
and i think you figure out
it's part of figuring out your story is
where do i fit in what is where can i
contribute
um and you know so for me that was not
in the accounting classroom
but there might have been other
classrooms um
you know on operations or optimization
was like okay like
this is relevant or there are cases on
you know perhaps on a mining company
something like that like okay like i
know what this is like
i can give context here but then even
outside of that
that's only one you know your background
is only one part of your story
there's also where you want to go is
another part of your story
and how can you contribute there how can
you so for me i wanted to go into
renewable energy
so i did the hyper i joined all the
energy classes i joined energy club
and then i was probably known more for
being interested in energy than for my
background and mining
[Music]
and so it's just a matter of
figuring out what's important to you and
then communicating that
and even though mining wasn't that
important to me
every time anything about money came up
everyone got pointed in my you know
towards me and said you know go talk to
him
i had professors who say oh they you
know um professor
investors saying oh they're interested
in the mining space and renewable energy
and they would set up coffee chats for
me to come talk to me then that
introduced me to other people in the
broader
both stanford network and even palo alto
network of people who also
working in mining and said you know
here's a rare
mining mba person like talk to them
so if you figure out what's important to
you and you communicate that
i think you find your fit and you'll
find the people with similar interests
and you'll find the people you should be
speaking to
i hope that answers the question oh yeah
that answered it beautifully
and it pops up a follow-up question i
have for carl
so graham talked a little bit about some
of the contributions his perspective
um contributed even classroom community
and now kind of in the broader scale of
folks who might have been interested and
are looking for someone to talk to and
learn more about
what are some of the ways that you saw
you've seen your
pre-mba background contribute or add
value to
either the classroom or conversations
you've had
well i think there's the obvious thing
about like whenever healthcare pops up
in a class like people would all turn to
me and be like oh carl what do you think
like
is that is that how this goes like we
literally
had a case in our optimization class
about
uh or scheduling at a hospital i had
worked at
um and we had another one about how to
optimize the processes in an anesthesia
clinic so it was very easy for me to be
like
so these are how these things would
happen um but even beyond that i think
a lot of the the the soft skills
portions like those are things that i
i have gotten to practice and will and
get to practice more every day like
telling people that their loved one is
dying or has
died like those are very difficult
conversations and there's a lot of
parallels that you can make between that
and uh firing people or
telling them that the company is going
bankrupt or you know making those big
announcements when you're a business
leader
and i think that i brought that unique
lens to those conversations that
um added a lot to the the conversations
really
nice um so as we're talking about the
gsb and the business school experience
let's start from the beginning of that
um from when classes started um this is
a question
from neptune out there um did you
feel behind in classes coming from uh
not coming from
a non-business background like what was
that transition
into the business classroom like for you
guys so um
maybe carl i'll start with you and then
graham will hop over to you next
yeah um it's definitely something i
worried about a little bit before
starting knowing that
i hadn't done math in over 10 years and
um
knew virtually nothing about accounting
finance or
whatever other classes you can think
you can think of when thinking of what a
first-year business student is taking
um but i i will say that they're
they're aware uh that people come in
with different levels and so a lot of
the
intro classes are tiered to make sure
that you um
you enter in at the right level and you
make sure that you learn
what you need to learn but also that
everybody is stimulated
um the other thing i think is that um
i um i coming from
an md background i had already done
graduate studies and already had a sense
of uh learning from myself and for what
i
for what i need to learn and for what i
need for my career versus learning in
order to
get specific grades um and so i think i
came into the program putting very
little pressure on myself and being like
i'm going to take as much as i can
but if there's this one piece of
information i
i can't memorize it for whatever reason
and i think there's something i can do
with my time
that would add more value to this
experience then that's what i'm gonna do
um and and i think that that really
helped me get through it
with uh with a minimal amount of amounts
of stress compared to some other people
who didn't have that
that view coming in yes and then
graham how about you how was that
transition um coming from a non-business
background
into the business classroom i think the
key thing is carl actually product is
knowing
what you want to get out of it and where
you need to put your time and attention
to
um and so if
you know if that's if you're coming from
a non-traditional background and
you say you already want to learn
finances okay then you know you need to
put your attention
into accounting and econ and
finance 101 and like ensure those
classes
will then take up more of your time but
because you know where you want to put
your attention
i think that really helps and and as
carl mentioned how they share the
classes is
the inter classes or the the first
sort of quarter is really key
because then you know my first year
accounting class was
everyone else who had never done
accounting before either
all people who were accountants were in
the third advanced or
the level three class basically and they
were doing
discussing some super advanced stuff i
don't i don't even know what they're
discussing but they weren't in our class
you know being bored or
asking questions that are just so far
above my head that i have no idea what's
going on
um so i think that's really critical i
think the other element to the
transition
is just being back in a classroom and
having to study and
and just being back in a classroom like
i hadn't done that
for five years and that is a bit of a
shock to the system again
um yeah and i think that's something to
be aware of but
again i think the first quarter
allows for that transition it's sort of
right the
the whole first quarter sort of ramps up
as well um
and like the the um without doing any
sports or the activities
where they're on hold and go and
participate in those i think really
helps as well
um graham there's a couple questions in
the q a box about like
eiffer did you know you wanted to do the
the program coming in
and what was it like with the two
programs like how did
what was that experience like um so i
didn't
know i wanted to do the program coming
in i happened to
have a small group dinner i think in my
first week
at stanford um which was hosted by a
second year ei per person
and two of or and then there are also
two classmates of mine
who were already in the ipad program and
then it's a joint before
or as they joined the nba um
and we just got talking about that and
it sounded awesome and i think the next
day i filled out the application
um so that is more by chance but i
definitely think it's worthwhile looking
into before if you know about
it um and then in terms of managing the
two
programs it's very flexible in terms of
how you manage it
um i think there's a slightly higher
overall
points requirement um i can't remember
exactly it's 120 240
or 120 or something like that
but you can do it anywhere from an extra
one quarter to an extra three quarters
at stanford so you can really decide if
you want to
almost like to do 20 units every quarter
for the
two years and one quarter you can finish
it quickly
in just one additional quarter and it'll
be busy but
you can do it if you want to take a much
more leisurely pace
for the whole thing you can do three
years to do both the nba and the anchor
and then have you know maybe one year
being busy and two
and one year medium and one really
really relaxed year
you can have three pretty relaxed years
you can
really split it up how you want to
and managing that
managing that is is up to you really and
what's again what's important and what
you want to get out of it
um the most challenging part is probably
managing the non-gsb um
classes that or or courses because
some of those will occur one year and
they won't occur again
or they'll occur two years and then
you're budgeting on doing it in the next
year
and it disappears or they're only
offered in spring quarter so
you've got to try the budget that you're
going to do in spring quarter and then
manage conflicts with other gsb
classes you want to do so it's really
about managing the schedule
of what's available when and and the
conflicts that might occur from that
oh yeah so a little bit more it just
takes a little bit of pre-planning and
coming through
but there are there's great support for
both gsb
and the ipad to help you manage that
process
um and they are very accommodating and
flexible if you just talk to them and
start discussions early
um so continuing on the theme of things
you did while you're at the gsb
carl you um went from healthcare
went back into healthcare graham you
went from mining
and then you went into consulting so we
have two different
um journeys here so carl if i can start
with you
um there's a question here in the inbox
from lewis about oh wait that's the
wrong one
sorry there is a question here about why
did you choose stanford for health care
um there's there's a bunch of reasons i
think one of it
is just the excellence of the hospital
system
and i knew that i could meet a lot of
people working within it
who i could see as contacts both
within the business side and within the
healthcare side
um i did for example do a quality
improvement project
uh with stanford healthcare while i was
at the gsb
um the other reason was um
the which which is kind of a roundabout
way to go about healthcare but
the the strong emphasis that stanford
puts on
interpersonal skills and on
communication skills
and those are so key in healthcare and i
was like even if i go into this degree
and decide that i hate business that i
never want to do it i never want to
manage people like i'm going to need to
manage relationships with patients and
i'm going to need to manage
uh difficult conversations and
and those are things that stanford is
going to teach me no matter what
um and so i think that was that was the
other thing that
really attracted me to stanford as
someone coming from healthcare
um i did take a lot of classes at the
med school as well during my two years
which i thought was a big plus like the
ability to take classes kind of
everywhere on campus
was very exciting to me um and took a
bunch of the
healthcare electives that were offered
at stanford and and really enjoyed them
and
learned a lot about like how the
healthcare industry is structured in the
u.s and abroad and how to
manage large healthcare organizations
what are the different experiments that
have been done
on the business side about that those
were all like super cool experiences for
me
so question so i'm gonna follow up a
little bit here
and adapt the question from daniel so
that original question was from nina so
sorry i got
names mixed up nina um but daniel's
asking
a little bit about transformation about
moments or an experience you have that
helped you change
in a way um how do you think you've
changed
even if your career trajectory and your
career goal remained the same like what
are some of the ways you've seen
yourself kind of grow or expand
from from your time at business school
[Music]
i think uh stanford gives you a lot of
opportunity for
feedback from other people like it's one
of the things that we're known for that
we even make jokes about uh like we give
each other feedback all the time and
it's a gift
um and so i think very early on
i was told something that had never been
told in health care and if that's that
um i i'm not very emotionally expressive
and uh that that sometimes
means that people take a bit of time to
figure out um
whether or not i'll like them and
i got like a million other little pieces
of feedback about
how i interact with other people and and
thinking about those and trying to work
on those and trying to find
uh strategies that work for me to
uh not i don't want to say overcome
because that's not really
like a a default but you know to work
around those little quirks that i have
have been really really helpful in how i
interact with other people
um i was i was stuck in an apartment
with my sister for three months at the
beginning of quarantine for example
and uh i was using some of the tricks
that i learned in interpersonal dynamics
like every single day
to prevent us from from murdering each
other
because sometimes it it got it got a
little heated
yes and then graham you you pivoted did
you
know that you wanted to go into
consulting
or like how did you um kind of
how did you know that you were going to
go in that direction like
i so i didn't know i will i will say
that
in my application i said i wanted to go
into consulting um
to learn business skills and this sort
of gets back to
iterating on your story so coming in i
thought okay that sounds like a
good story to tell um and it made sense
to me and it made sense
for how i saw my career progressing
then i joined stanford got um decided i
want to go
more into renewables and energy and join
the iper
and i was like okay i forget this
consulting thing let me go into clean
energy startup
let me try that
did that discovered
that startups depending very much on the
startup are not necessarily
always a great place to work
[Music]
and then sort of looked saying okay i've
tried that
where do i see myself going now and
actually came back
back to the idea of consulting
um because of again it's almost an
extension of
an mba just learning skills
faster career progression
opening more doors but then also just
because i do
enjoy sort of solving different
problems and consulting promised to be a
lot of that
yeah did you um how did you explore the
startup space was this
during the gsb or was this like
immediately after
this was during the gsp um
so it was you know a lot of discussions
with some classmates even who
who had worked in startups who had their
own startups
um or were starting something it was
with
other you know alumni or other just
people
within the sort of energy startup
ecosystem that
classmates or the stanford community
helped me help connect me to
um and then speaking to them and then
sort of eventually picking one and going
for it
[Music]
so definitely a big part of of exploring
at the gsb
and then same question from daniel for
you
about transformation and change is there
a moment or experience that has
helped you kind of grow in some way
shape or form
i can't pick out a sort of a singular
moment where i had
an aha moment um i didn't think
but i think i just grew a lot of gsb and
really from
people's diverse perspectives
[Music]
and i think it helped me
become even more open and
aware of how i interact with people with
different backgrounds and experiences
and i thought that growing up in south
africa and dealing with this sort of
continuous basis that i was already
pretty good at this
and then at the gsb i think it just
it grew so much particularly in that
regard
[Music]
and that was again the class
interpersonal dynamics that carl
mentioned
um also in study philly some of you
might heard
that class was incredible but just the
the general discussions
um i think it really helped to break
down
any stereotypes you might have um
because you'd meet people who just did
not fit
whatever stereotype you had about
someone with some background or anything
you'd meet someone who completely
shattered that stereotype
and it just made me question a lot of
the stereotypes i had
and then just that event you say you
know what this is just not helping me
having these
are times let me just try to forget
those um
i think that for me was has been key
i have a question here from mattai so
we've kind of
run the gauntlet from kind of where you
came from healthcare and mining
approaching the process that transition
begin classes career exploration or
acceleration
as the case may be this question is from
matthias
how do you compare yourself post to
pre-mba at stanford
if you had to put it in a few words so
go ahead and take
a few moments graham you just responded
so maybe carl we'll start with you
um how would you describe yourself like
how would you compare yourself
pre versus post stanford mba
um i think there's a few things the the
one thing is
it's really expanded my idea of what's
possible
and what are the different things i
could do in the different directions i
could go i think
one one quick example is like the power
of just like asking for what you want
um is that's something that the gsb
taught me so in my
in the fall quarter of my my second year
i emailed like four different hospital
ceos
uh in toronto where where i live
currently and just like
told them told them my story told them
like look basically i want your job
someday like
would you mind getting on the phone for
like 20 30 minutes and telling me how
you got there and
what do i do to do this i don't think
that's something i would have had
the courage or even like think thought
thought about doing before the gsb
and like they all responded they all
said yes they all got on the phone with
me so i learned a ton from those
conversations and just like knowing that
that's something i can do
i think was a really big learning
experience for me
and then the other thing is just being
very intentional
about how i interact with people
how i uh make like appreciation feel
known how i express
my feelings and things like that um
those those are all very different from
when i came to stanford and
when i when i left stanford and then the
last thing is
i think a lot of like new skills that i
learned like in terms of like how to
manage an organization
how to read a balance sheet like i sit
on a few boards right now and i'm just a
much more thoughtful
and deliberate board member and can ask
much better questions just because i
have a better sense of how organizations
are run i learned
i learned spanish while i was there as
well um
so have have had a few patients who
greatly benefited from that because
i had a couple who were just unilingual
spanish speakers and
got to give them their treatment in
their first language which was pretty
cool
and graham what about you how would you
describe yourself pre
versus post um mba
so i think i was bowling off what i said
before i think i'm much more
open and aware of so open to
different perspectives different ideas
aware of my own biases and
how i come across and then better able
to work with other people
and like i said like communicate with
them
um i think much more
aware of how you know i think emotions
play a role in relationships as well i
had
always sort of seen showing
vulnerability and asking for help as a
so i suppose as a weakness and i think
stanford really helped me to see how
those can be used or how those can be
beneficial
and how they can be really really
actually critical to building
relationships
um similarly then also just
a lot of the hard skills and i feel
i might not be an expert in accounting
or reading balance sheets or
you know human resources but i could
have a meaningful discussion in any of
those areas
if i needed to and
you know i sort of know what to ask know
what the critical things
are and how to dive deep into that
and then also importantly know that it's
okay to ask for help it's okay
i can have a an entry-level discussion
to this but
i can't go deep who do we speak to you
can help me with this
and being comfortable to ask for that
help
is is a big change i think
as we continue this progression through
the experience from
having a stem background again to where
you are now
looking back so we're now we're in the
reflective phase
um looking back and this is a question
from michael if you could do
the graduate school process over again
is there anything that you would do
differently so graham maybe we can start
with you
yeah i i would be more intentional about
how i spent my time um
i think there is there's a
perception or
not it is a bit of a culture but it's
not a it's not necessarily real
and that's why i said perception of
grades don't matter
academics don't matter we're here to
have fun and like
socialize and network and while that's
true i think i let that
took it almost too literally and i think
there's more that i could have learned
which i would have liked to have learned
if i was more intentional about it um
at the same time i think i would have
changed my strategy of
forming more meaningful connections with
maybe fewer people
um you know and i suppose focusing on
fewer connections with
or stronger connections with fewer
people um
and so i would have probably changed
those two approaches a bit
but otherwise not too significantly yet
um
i think that just being really
intentional about how you spend your
time is
the most important thing and i would be
more intentional about that
carl what about yourself i think
it's almost a joke but i think i would
do it completely differently do
everything differently just so i could
get an experience that's just like
nothing like what i had um i loved the
time i had but there's just so many
opportunities that come
with being at stanford in the mba
program and
um there's always this sense that like
whenever you're doing something you're
you're missing out on 10 others um and
so like just
going back and open that door that i
didn't open like maybe i don't know
learn how to code or
go on that trip that i didn't go to uh
get to meet the other people that i
didn't get to meet
uh lean in really hard on the like hard
finance skills and see
see where that gets me and if that gets
me somewhere different
yes um were there any like classes or
um programs specifically that you you
would go back and
try again if you had a second chance
yeah i think i would try to learn how to
code
um i forget exactly what class code
those are but they're they're across the
street classes
about how to use like r and python um
and i think that would be a very
interesting skill to have
plus like there's a lot of things that
you can do with it
in any industry you go into so maybe
that's one thing i would try
yeah i i think you might be referring to
uh cs 106 or css 105
those are two of the uh known classes on
campus for
for being in this computer science space
yes exactly those
um graham i'm i'm curious if there was
any if there was a class or program or
something that you would try
if you had a second chance at business
school
yeah i really like carl's approach of
saying try something completely new and
different and don't look at the same
experience twice
i think that's great i think um and i
suppose to that i would have
probably leaned in more on some of the
heavy finances so there's an investments
class there's a financial modeling class
by the mars or
um i think probably was trying to lean
in really heavily there
and then and then maybe even like i did
start off garage my
very last quarter i think i would have
liked to maybe do it a bit earlier and
then also maybe try a
d-school class i think it would be
really cool um can you tell us what
startup garage is
yes startup garage is um
it's a class there are a couple of
different
it's often different quarters to sort of
build on from each quarter
where you sort of come with an idea and
really try to build a startup out or
from that idea
and you've got a couple mentors guides
who
act as professors um most of them are
from industry
and they sort of help guiding through
that process of helping to
hone in what is your idea what is the
mvp
and the minimum product can you build
that can you test that
can you see if there's a market for it
um and this will just take you through
that process
and that's it's been some really there's
been some great startups that have
actually come out and really successful
startups that have come out of that
class
um
and as we think back
now onto like the advice and best
practice and tips part
um where we get to impart some of your
wisdom um from having
lived it for folks uh maybe we'll take
this specifically for folks maybe either
coming from your own
professional or educational background
or from stem in general
do you have any tips best practices
words of wisdom
that you could share with folks as we
close out today's events
so graham maybe we can start with you
um so something i've said
before i keep on hopping back to it is
just knowing
knowing what you want to get out of the
program
and i think it is particularly important
for stem people understand
background and knowing because
because that isn't necessary to say you
want to get out
you know a finance knowledge or business
document maybe you have an idea you want
to take through startup garage
but i think it's knowing what you want
to get out and then really
honing in on that the second comes to a
point
someone raised and asked about fitting
in
is don't worry about that figure out
your story for yourself
be vocal about that and you will fit in
by being yourself
um and you will find the right place
and there was a third thing i was going
to say which i've not forgotten
but those two are i think the third is
is related to that don't if you want to
focus on academics or something
[ __ ] whatever you want to focus on
whatever is important to you
do that regardless of what other people
say um
and if you say hey you really want to
learn accounting and people are saying
why accounting is so boring if that's
what you want to do that's what's
important to you
ignore them and go and do it and
remember that everyone is struggling
to figure out what they want to do as
well you're not alone in that
what what's the saying for successful
speech writing tell them what you're
going to say
then tell them and then tell them what
you just said so already
still practicing some of those effective
communication techniques
and then carl what about yourself any
tips best practices words of wisdom you
have for folks out there
yeah graham kind of stole mine actually
i was gonna say
like come in with a list of the things
you want to accomplish
and try to make sure that your time is
aligned with those so i i came in with
three specific goals i wanted to
learn how to manage a healthcare
organization learn better
communication interpersonal skills and
learn a new language
and when looking at my classes and
looking at how i spent my time the clubs
i joined
i was very intentional about doing that
that being said uh i think there's also
something to be said about
exploring and trying things that take
you out of your comfort zone
so yes do come in with goals and make
sure you align your time with them
uh but leave a little bit of space for a
little bit of whimsy and last minute
decisions
and exploration awesome we have
one more poll if you guys everyone would
be willing to help us out here
thank you so much to our panelists
carl graham for sharing your time your
story and your wisdom with us
all um i encourage you to go ahead and
if you're interested in learning more
including what other events we're having
you can create
your own personalized dashboard at
mystanford.nba
where we'll help curate some of the
things that might be of most interest to
you
with the answer of a few short questions
so once again
thank you so much for joining us today
and i hope to see you again at
some of our other events this summer
have a wonderful evening
day morning wherever in the world you
are take care and stay safe